[Musique]
whoa merde parce que nous nous connaissons
depuis 30 ans mais comme littéralement c'est
un à part
mon album préféré sur lequel nous avons travaillé cet
album marque 20 ans depuis le
premier album de
Black Eyed Peas donc Black Eyed Peas ce premier album est
sorti en  1998 et 20 ans plus tard 2018 et
nash's of the Sun, c'est donc la raison
pour laquelle, parmi tous nos disques, ce disque
mentionne que le Soleil ressemble plus à un
disque de corbillard derrière le devant
qu'à la fin, il a donc décidé de
célébrer plus de 20 ans si  Je conduis
dans la voiture ma chanson préférée revient à la
vie après avoir fait du vélo
ma chanson préférée est où est un peu en
ce moment quand je suis rentré à la maison ou dans la voiture
constante
ouais constante dans la voiture mais est
constituée ou à notre fer sont gros  amour
grande belle journée amour ouais bingo
si je marche dans la ville grand amour
ouais marche je travaille maintenant si je m'entraîne
à la fin
oh ouais nous avons une audition le premier amour
est ici en France bingo